with me now is CBS News chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett along with
special correspondent Alex Wagner who is
also co-host of the circus on Showtime
good morning guy morning how you doing
this morning I've been to the Drake
diner before it's a great place to be a
lot of candidates have been here as well
as the hashbrowns and the French toast
sticks all right major I want to start
with you go this is really a toss-up
here we've got Jill Biden and Bernie
Sanders tied in our poll but other
people say Biden could be first or it
could be fourth yes and that is the
great anxiety of the Biden campaign
Biden's entire fate and I was going to
depend on how well he is organized
statewide Bernie Sanders in a very good
position to win this first or fourth you
don't hear Sanders people saying that
you're them saying first or second first
or fourth is a huge gap for Biden if
he's well-organized who get those second
realignment choices and move close to
Bernie Sanders also keep an eye on
Elizabeth Warren Pete Budaj edge is well
organized you've got four campaigns all
thoroughly organized and competitive Joe
Biden played pundit on Friday said you
know if it's all 21 20 19 18 we all just
go to the next place there's no real
winner but if he's fourth he's the big
loser in Iowa so Alex Iowa went for
President Obama in the general election
twice then swung to president Trump what
are you hearing from voters about which
of these Democratic candidates could
swing it back into the blue camp well I
mean the the mythic Obama Trump voter is
that this is sort of central to the
Democratic Party I think maybe these
people they exist but I mean I will say
Tony
we must not overstate I mean we must not
understate in fact the chasm that has
opened up between the two parties in
this particular moment in the age of
Trump and it is an open question about
whether you can bring Trump voters back
to the fold having said that I think the
moderate wing of the Democratic Party
would like to do it and so with the
progressive wing they have different
prescriptions on how to do it but
whether it's structural change or coming
up with a 20-18 playbook in 2020 that
will once again return
moderates into the bowl at the end of
the day Iowa voters are particularly
interested in trade it's something a
year candidates of all stripes talk
about on the ground
here climate change this is an
agricultural State Iowans Carolyne about
it gun safety reform people are not
talking about impeachment and they are
focused on the bread-and-butter economic
issues that it sounds like we've heard
the story before but it's true true true
especially in this state truisms are
true for a reason major one person who
has not been campaigning here in Iowa is
Mayor Mike Bloomberg former New York
City Mayor sighs how is he affecting
this race if at all and how will this
race affect his chances he's not
affecting this race but he is affecting
the psychology of the early contests the
first for which he is not participating
in though he may be a debate participant
sooner rather than later if Joe Biden
does not do well here then the idea the
entire Bloomberg kandacy takes on more
relevancy because he will tell the
Democratic Party your presumed
frontrunner the former vice president
couldn't get it done in Iowa if Biden
does really well here wins or comes in a
strong second the Bloomberg strategic
pitch to Democrats is a bit weakened so
Biden and Bloomberg are tied together
here in ways they might not have
contemplated even six weeks ago it may
be the most competitive caucus in caucus
history guys yes Alex major Garrett
thank you very much we'll leave it there
and Anthony we're gonna send it back to
you in New York
all right thanks Tony we'll hear more
from you in from Iowa throughout the
morning
you